hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel
i know it's been a minute since i've
posted um
i've had a lot going on but i'm back in
business i swear
so today i am going to be reacting to
spin up
young g ace and fast money goon who i
smoke the official music video
before i start do not forget to go to my
instagram the link is in the bio below
i do polls on my instagram for which
which songs i should react to
this was a request from my instagram so
if you want to be a part of that process
do not forget to follow me
[Music]
[Music]
this is a good song
[Music]
okay so he said something important he
said 12
paramedics could not save your life so
what i've learned is that's like
basically a threat so he's threatening
someone he's saying that like even if
you have paramedics i'm gonna
i'm guessing shoot i don't see guns but
you know
i'm guessing shoot them in the street
that's the end of your life
okay i like how they're
i hate how much i like this song
because one the original song is a bop
two i don't know i just kind of like the
idea
of having them all in the golf course i
think that's creative
and three like it's catchy this is
one of my favorite songs i've listened
to what i would say
about this is that
it's just a lot of threats like he's
trying to tell people
how like i don't want to say hard but i
can't think of a better word but like
how he has more power than them
basically whether that's guns
like he's saying like nothing you can do
is gonna save your life
pretty much
okay so he said knock uh out
so he's saying like i literally will
knock you out
like so i thought it was guns before he
could be
talking fists you know i don't i don't
think it really matters
[Music]
he's basically saying that one he
doesn't need a female
like he he's not tied to a female he
doesn't need one
and two it's going back to the threats
he mentioned
he mentioned bringing his gun no matter
where he goes
okay so the observation i have of this
part is
i would pay to go golfing this
with these guys i don't golf i don't
i don't even like golfing but
they look like they're having a ton of
fun like if this is what golfing's like
i understand the draw like this looks
like a blast
[Music]
okay at the end they're just talking
about how they smoke
this could be a variety of substances
i'm guessing weed
but i think there's other drugs you can
smoke too
i'm not overly sure if you enjoyed that
reaction let me know in the comments
i like this song a lot this is the first
10 out of 10
i think i've given on this channel but
that song
a hundred percent deserves a 10 out of
10 like i was bopping my head the whole
time
if you enjoyed this reaction and you
want to see more do not forget to like
comment and subscribe especially
subscribe guys the more subscribers i
have
the better i can like i'm just more
motivated
like when you guys aren't subscribing
like i don't really feel like doing
these because i feel like no one wants
to watch them so if you want to keep
watching my content
if you want to let me know that you
enjoy this stuff please please subscribe
and do not forget to leave a like and
leave a comment too i will talk to you
guys next time bye